today the Matt wall show the White House
is becoming less and less white in fact
and this is a fact we're supposed to
celebrate we'll discuss the left's
obsession with diversity and how
diversity is really a code word for
anti-white bigotry also Ronda Santos
orders the execution of a twice
convicted murderer who stabbed a young
woman to death according to the media
DeSantis is the real bad guy in that
story somehow plus Liam Neeson has his
own me too moment while appearing on The
View a new study shows that hormone
therapy for Trans identified people is
having a disastrous impact on their
health who would have possibly thought
that's the case in our daily
cancellation a teacher tries to explain
why parents shouldn't have any real say
over what their kids are taught all that
and more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
are we back on well clearly someone in
the control room forgot to turn on
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
encrypts 100 of my online data to
protect it from cyberpunks like the ones
who tried to terrorize my show today
when I use expressvpn my online presence
is anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
try to shut me down couldn't be easier
to set up you just tap one button on
your phone or computer and you're
protected expressvpn works on all your
devices your phone tablet computer
wherever you are in the world expressvpn
can and will protect you don't let the
cyberpunks who tried to hijack my show
hijack your information visit
expressvpn.com Walsh get three extra
months for you that's exp
ressvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh
to learn more
you may believe that the Biden
Administration has been nothing but a
parade of incompetence and catastrophe
you may look around and see Financial
Devastation inflation crumbling
infrastructure non-existent border
rampant crime an epidemic of drug
overdoses of failing education system
are unnecessary entanglements and
conflicts overseas which may lead to a
global nuclear war potentially and all
of this while Chinese spy balloons float
casually over our heads and you may
after surveying this rather discouraging
scene come to the conclusion that the
people leading our country have
performed in a manner that may be
described as less than adequate you may
think all of that and you may even be
right in fact you are right but the
White House is here to tell you that
none of that matters because what really
matters is diversity
and uh when it comes to the diversity
contest they will take second place to
No One indeed White House Press
Secretary Karen Jean pair herself a
woman who checks multiple diversity
boxes took another opportunity to Tout
The administration's diversity record
and this was in response to a question
from the ever Vigilant press and the
press that is always focused on what the
American people care about
um and it was a question about the
appointment of the next Federal Reserve
Vice chairman or chairwoman or
chairperson or chair them the reporter
wanted to know whether they would be
looking for diverse applicants because
obviously it's very important that the
Federal Reserve Vice chairperson
represents a marginalized group this
will be a source of inspiration for all
the people in that group who had always
dreamed since childhood of becoming the
Federal Reserve Vice chairperson and if
you're in such a group and had such a
dream as so many have then this response
from Karen Jean Parish should be very
encouraging listen
but I want to take the opportunity to to
lay out what how diverse the president's
cabinet has been how diverse the
president's Administration has been the
cabinet is majority people of color for
the first time in history the cabin is a
majority female for the first time in
history a majority of white house senior
staff identify as female 40 of White
House senior staff identify as part of
the racially diverse communities and a
record seven assistance to the president
are openly lgbtq plus so again this is
something that the president Prides
himself on that he actually has taken
action to show the diversity of this
Administration
you know just an impromptu question from
the press that she happened to have a
written speech ready for with uh you
know all the statistics and the exact
number of uh racial minorities that are
in the Bible she just happened to have
that on hand for this question from the
press and by the way maybe she really
did you know I I it maybe she actually
does have that information on it maybe
she just goes to every press conference
and has all that information we got 40
uh you know gay people we've got because
that from the by administration's
perspective that could be an answer to
any question at all I mean the question
could be what are we gonna do about the
price of eggs well you know here at the
bite Administration uh we have here's
the number of uh polysexuals we have
they just they see that as the somehow
the solution to every problem
so in other words
all that is to say the most incompetent
Administration in American history
is also the most diverse
make of that what you will in fact
it's impossible to think of an example
of an organization institution a
profession
that has become more effective as it has
become more diverse there's lots of
Institutions we could think of that have
become more quote unquote diverse
but how many of them have been improved
by that in any measurable way whatsoever
we hear that diversity is our strength
but there isn't any evidence anywhere of
diversity producing anything that would
qualify as strength in fact what we see
nearly across the board is institutional
decline
coinciding with the diversifying of
those same institutions
make of that what you will too
but here's what you should make of it
and it's this that diversity as an end
in itself
will always produce decline as an end in
itself
no institution no community no country
will prosper by focusing on diversity
for diversity's sake diversity the sort
that the Bible ministration tells anyway
should be a byproduct not an aim in
other words if you recruit people
because they're the most qualified the
most skilled the most effective which is
the only reason you should be recruiting
anyone for anything really
um and as a byproduct of that approach
you end up with a more quote-unquote
diverse organization then fine though it
would also be fine if the approach
resulted in an organization that was
predominantly white or predominantly
male as long as by the end of it the
organization is best able to accomplish
whatever it's designed to accomplish
because that's what matters
okay because and then if you have that
the demographic makeup whatever that
happens to be is good because it was the
result of a merit-based recruitment
strategy
well the problem is that diversity is
rarely a byproduct in our society it is
it is not organic it's not something
that just happens uh it's always almost
always engineered and engineered
diversity is never good engineer
diversity is the work of bureaucrats who
stand above you know the mass of common
people and declare from on high that
certain races have exceeded their
allotted percentages
so other races must be shipped in and
installed to fix the problem they have
decided
now all of this is arbitrary and it's
it's completely dehumanizing
you know you're taking away people's
Humanity reducing them to statistics a
white person is not a white person
according to the White House
he's a faceless representative for his
race which is apparently running some
sort of surplus the uh the supply
exceeds the demand as far as they're
concerned anyway and so we've got to
clear out the stock and then restock
with more valuable demographics is
essentially the uh the approach so this
is essentially how our social Engineers
view the problem which is only a problem
in the first place because they've
decided to call it a problem and notice
also that the allotted percentages are
not based on representation in the
population see the diversity proponents
they always say that institutions should
reflect the communities they serve we
just heard that yesterday from CNN about
the medical profession they were saying
we need more black doctors because there
are a lot of black patients and it has
to reflect we have to reflect uh the the
diversity of the of the population now
even that would be ridiculous and
arbitrary there's no reason why every
institution should reflect the racial
makeup of the larger Community or Nation
again it should reflect whatever is the
result of merit-based recruitment
but this is especially the case when
this demand for representation is only
applied to Industries and organizations
that the Elites in our culture consider
admirable or desirable or useful
so for example only 10 of car mechanics
are black
which is actually an underrepresentation
in compared to the overall population
but you rarely hear them raise that as a
problem
because the people who raise these kinds
of problems don't happen to respect car
mechanics or consider it to be a
desirable profession
in spite of the fact that car mechanics
belong to one of the most important
professions in existence right now
because without them modern society
ceases to function basically
but when it comes to the desirable
professions the professions that the
elites consider desirable anyway
percentage-based representation as
ridiculous as that would be on its own
is not actually what they're after of
course
they say they want these institutions to
reflect the diversity of the American
people but if it did
that would mean that they would shoot
for 13 black and 60 White
if the White House really reflected the
American people it would not be as Jean
pair says a majority people of color
because the the the population isn't
that's not representation that is a
considerable over-representation
yet of course over representation is the
actual goal because diversity is not the
actual goal diversity is a smoke screen
I mean there's a reason why these days
leftists have taken to I'm sure you've
noticed referring to diverse people
or rather a diver a diverse person so
it's not just that the ethnic makeup of
a group of people
can be considered diverse it's an
individual human being can be diverse
you know you could have a diverse person
and then a non-diverse person
this makes no sense from a definitional
perspective because diversity means
variety and difference one individual
cannot be a variety
collections of people can have variety
individuals in a vacuum cannot so what
does it mean to describe a person as
diverse
well it means obviously that the person
isn't white that's all it means
and especially that the person isn't a
white straight male diversity is code
for non-white
and so anytime they talk about making
something more diverse what they're
saying is they want fewer white people
fewer males and fewer straight people
now
I know we've grown accustomed to this
kind of bigotry but we we shouldn't fail
to appreciate how twisted and ultimately
terrifying it is that the White House
is openly boasting about discriminating
against whites
this is racial bigotry brought to the
highest levels
and paraded around in the open
that's a very concerning development
that's why our reaction to this sort of
thing should no longer be as it has been
for so long to just scoff at it you know
like it's a silly thing
the goal to make institutions especially
governmental institutions more diverse
is not merely a bunch of politically
correct nonsense though it is also that
but it is mainly
um you know actively racist it is an
actively racist campaign against whites
and an actively sexist campaign against
males it is a direct effort to uh
marginalize a group of people that the
powers that be despise
that's how we should see it because
that's what it is and we should react
accordingly
any effort to make any institution less
white and less male is not only
pointless and silly but disgusting
and morally repugnant
as would be entirely clear to everyone
if an institution we openly endeavored
to make its members less black or less
brown or less female
and this is not just about complaining
about a double standard here you know I
know we do plenty of that
I'm saying that we need to start calling
things what they are which means that
we must say
that our government is run not by
champions of diversity
but by anti-white bigots plain and
simple
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
have you gone to the grocery store and
not been able to find something as
simple as eggs then when you do find
them of course they're almost nine
dollars a dozen there are shortages and
you should be concerned about no matter
what the media tries to tell you
shortages aren't just happening with
global pandemics and natural disasters
they're happening every day and if
you're worried about not being able to
find the products you need to take care
of yourself and your family well you
should be it's understandable to feel
anxious and uncertain times but there's
a way to feel at peace even in the midst
of shortages you need to be prepared for
anything and our partners at Jace
medical are here to help with that a
great way to start preparing is with the
Jace case a pack of five different
courses of antibiotics that you can use
to treat a whole host of bacterial
illnesses all you have to do is fill out
a simple online form your information
will be reviewed by a board certified
physician and your medication will be
dispensed by a licensed pharmacy at a
fraction of the regular cost being
prepared not only brings peace of mind
but also helps you save time and money
in the long run but you got to go to
jacemedical.com enter code wall should
check out for a discount on your order
that's jacemedical.com promo code Welsh
we'll begin with this because the media
found a new line of attack against
DeSantis last night the line of attack
is that DeSantis had a man killed if you
could a poor innocent man was killed by
Ron DeSantis and that man's name is
Donald dilbeck
um of course uh it turns out this poor
innocent man was uh was was not either
of those things well he might be poor
but he's not innocent uh he's a murderer
on death row but here's how The
Huffington Post reported on this story
okay
this is our headline
Florida executes man used as political
Pawn by Ron DeSantis
subheading I know I heard a lot of
people when I was young I really messed
up said Donald dilbeck who was sentenced
to death by a non-unananimous jury but I
know Ron DeSantis has done a lot worse
um no he hasn't done worse than you as a
convicted Murder on Death Row although
there's no point of addressing Donald
dilbeck now because he's you know dead
as well he should be
um read it now from the article says
Florida on Thursday executed 59 year old
Donald dilbeck who was sentenced to
death 32 years ago by a non-unanimous
charity under a death penalty statute
that has since been found
unconstitutional dilbeck was found as
was killed as punishment for fatally
stabbing a woman named Faye van and was
the first person executed in Florida
since 2019. the timing of his execution
appears to be part of a push by Governor
Ron DeSantis to bring back death
sentences by non-unanimous juries the
scientist who was expected to run for
president signed dilbeck's death warrant
last month on the same day that he
floated changing state law to allow
non-unanimous juries to impose death
sentences
maybe eight out of 12 have to agree or
something Dan is dead to Santa suggested
that a Florida sheriff's Association
conference just before ordering the
execution of a man with that exact jury
split
uh I know I heard people when I was
young I really messed up but Dale Beck
said we've already heard that but no
rotten Sanders has done a lot worse he's
taken a lot from a lot of people I speak
for all men women and children he's put
his foot on our necks Ron DeSantis and
other people like him can
sexual expletives
not no uh uh you you don't speak for
Donald you don't speak for all men you
don't speak for me at all you're a
convicted murderer who's now um dead and
uh decomposing in an unmarked grave as
you well deserve and so you don't speak
you don't really speak for for any
normal decent person
uh in a written statement Van's children
Tony and Laura van thank DeSantis for
carrying out the execution quote we were
robbed of the years of memories with her
and has been very painful ever since
however the execution has given us some
closure shortly after desantis's jury
suggestion Republican lawmakers filled
uh filed a set of bills that would
replace the unanimous jury requirement
with an eight to four threshold and
allow a judge to overrule a jury to
impose a death sentence
I'm not minimizing what dilback did to
people Florida capital Defender Allison
Miller told the towels he had
Tallahassee Democrat but he is most
definitely a political Pawn
the scientist has cited the outcome of
the trial for Nicholas Cruz who killed
17 people in 2018 school shooting in
Parkland Florida as a reason to bring
back non-unanimous jury verdicts
Cruz was sentenced to life in prison
without parole after juror split 93 over
the death penalty and that's an
important detail that I think maybe some
people get confused about with this
um
they're not talking about
you know the the conviction
is is uh non-unananas what they're
saying is that the decision you that you
could be executed even if
the entire jury doesn't agree that
although you're guilty you should be
executed for the crime
and of course Rhonda stands is entirely
right about that
I think why do you need the entire jury
to agree on that
um
and then we're told more now there's
something missing from as we read
through this entire report and this is
Huffington Post but the rest of the
corporate media it's been the same kind
of thing as they're telling us a story
about Donald dilbeck
um
and uh then they get to a little bit of
dilbeck's background like most people
sent us to death dilbeck endured extreme
abuse as a child his birth mother drank
18 to 24 beers per day throughout her
pregnancy resulting in a catastrophic
effect on Mr dilbeck's intellectual and
adaptive functioning his lawyers wrote
in a petition requesting a supreme court
review of the case that Mr Delbert
suffers from neurobehavioral disorder
associated with prenatal alcohol
exposure is Thoroughly medically
documented unrebutted and factually
Beyond dispute colors continue and then
they and then they go out they go on for
another several paragraphs telling us
the poor story of this poor man
poor guy but do you notice something how
we that uh something that's missing
we've got several paragraphs into this
and what's missing is they still haven't
given us the precise details of what
dilbeck did to earn his lethal ejection
they briefly mention it in one sentence
they don't really give us the full story
and this is always the case with these
kinds of articles about criminals
executed by the state
they always bury the reason
the full reason at the bottom when that
should be like the very first thing you
tell us
okay before you tell us about fetal
alcohol syndrome and he had a bad
upbringing and his parents were abusive
we don't need that I want to know what
he did well the full story of what he
did
well the full story is that dilbeck shot
and killed a sheriff's deputy
went to prison for it escaped
and then found a woman in the parking
lot Faye van in a parking lot of a store
and stabbed her to death really for no
reason uh not that there could be a good
reason stabbed her to death and left her
two children without a mother
and that's how we got the Deathbed
so killing first person not enough
second person now you're getting the
death penalty
and that's why like I can have all the
sympathy in the world for people who
experience trauma in their lives who are
abused as children like who can't who's
not sympathetic to that
but
once you victimize someone else
then the sympathy goes away
because you know
part of it is that the Buck has to stop
somewhere
and okay uh Donald dilbeck was abused as
a child terrible thing
well what about the parents who abused
him I bet you we could trace back and
see that well they were abused too
right I'm sure horrible things happen to
them when they were when they were
horrible things happened that would lead
a mother to drink 18 beers a day when
she's pregnant like we can guarantee
that she had not a great life I think we
can without even knowing anything else
about her we were pretty sure that's the
case
and then what about the people that did
that to her and then her and so you just
you just keep you keep passing the buck
down generations and generation
Generations turns out no one is
responsible for anything
it's got to stop somewhere and it
actually stops with each individual
stops with each individ each individual
is responsible for their own actions
and
if you are horribly victimized uh as a
child or any other time
again sympathy
but when you decide when you make the
decision to pass that victimization on
to someone else
right to try to in whatever weird
Twisted way uh alleviate your own
suffering or reclaim some you know
semblance of power and control in your
own sick Mind by passing that that
suffering and that victimization on
someone else now there's no more
sympathy for you
because now you're as bad in fact
probably worse now than the person who
victimized you
you are also a monster
so all that goes out the window
um
and this is just Justice
right we could talk about as we've
talked about with the death penalty
you know things like deterrence that is
a factor
okay they'll tell you the study show
it's not a deterrent
um first of all it's it's actually
impossible to
Common Sense tells us that obviously the
the death penalty has a deterrent Factor
because most people don't want to be
executed so it's got It's got obviously
it does
it's hard to go beyond common sense like
it's actually impossible to measure
someone they tell you that there's
studies it proves that there's no
deterrence well that would that would
that would require you
to know all of the people who would have
done something bad but then didn't
so you'd have to that's how that's the
only way to measure deterrence
you're measuring all of the people who
didn't do something
how could you possibly know that it's
impossible to know
and then also the way that we carry out
the death but I mean this guy was on
death row for decades
and so there's still a deterrence Factor
but that deterrence is obviously going
to be incredibly mitigated because we
don't execute very many people at all
it's very rare and when we do it's
decades in the past in the in the future
they get all kinds of appeals and
everything and so that's going to
mitigate the deterrence right there is
still going to be a deterrence factor
it's going to mitigate it though
and and yeah so the the turns thing you
could talk about that
um
you could talk about the kind of
societal self-defense argument
that there are people who are just so
dangerous that we have no choice but to
but to segregate them permanently from
all of society in the mo in the most
ultimate sort of form of segregation
which is which is to execute them
so that argument's fine but but it's but
really it comes down to Justice and
there are things in life that you can do
that that simply call out they cry out
for the harshest response and Punishment
and this is one of those things
and uh
and it that doesn't change your your
experiences growing up what you suffered
through
that's not that doesn't change the
nature of the act that you committed
ultimately though this just makes me
like DeSantis more a convicted killer
used his last moment on Earth
to curse the name of Ron DeSantis that's
supposed to make us like him less
not for me
All Right Moving On The Ladies of the
view discuss the East Palestine
situation you know you're going to get
some really intelligent commentary from
these ladies and
let's watch
for a second because it seems to me that
the Republicans are obsessed with this
notion of the free market and they don't
like a lot of regulations because it
means profit regulate yeah
there were very few plane crashes thank
God and that's because the industry is
highly regulated we have to pay for
regulation and safety standards
otherwise where are we we're all going
to go up in Flames Norfolk Southern
gives as much Democrats as Republicans
it's a very powerful Lobby that is
trying to block regulation and this
train to Sarah's point two miles long
with two full-time employees and a
trainee on it
because the last Administration rolled
it down to only one having worker they
happen to have two one thing I just want
to say is I do think this was an
unforced error by President Biden it was
20 days before we had secretary Buddha
judge go down 10 days before he put out
a statement acknowledging it yeah this
is Trump country he won by 40 points he
is for all Americans I believe that but
he needs to show that yes but it was
time for him people I don't know why
they would ever vote for him
by the way he plays someone with deep
ties to the chemical industry in charge
of the epa's chemical safety office
that's who you voted for in that
District Donald Trump who reduces all
safety he did McDonald's voters saw
something on the ground that probably
resonates but they need to look past the
photo locks these people and say who's
doing the job here forget about the
photo ops showing up is a big showing up
I think I think this is Donald Trump's
fault
uh of course it's Donald Trump's fault
um everything that happens in the Bible
restriction is Donald Trump's fault and
uh it's even just Donald Trump's fault
that not only that this happened but
that the by Administration didn't show
any concern for it whatsoever until they
were forced to and even then it was
clear that it was only a symbolic
concern the fact that the transportation
secretary didn't show up there for until
until three weeks and then uh walked
around for a little bit looking like a
dork in his uh in his construction
outfit looked like it looked like a
child dressing up as a construction
worker all that is Donald Trump's fault
so we know that
this is why I told you that
they and when I say they I mean the
media uh the the government
the elites
they don't care about this story because
they don't care about these people and
it really is that simple and they don't
care about these people because they
don't belong to to an accepted
um you know uh preferred group because
they're largely white Working Class
People and also because they tend to
vote
um Republican and you just heard it from
Joy Behar this is who you voted for
referring to them as these these people
this is who you voted for
you notice you would never ever ever say
that
about the crime-ridden
hellscape uh inner cities all across
country
just plagued with crime and violence and
drugs and people walking around looking
like zombies fentanyl zombies walking
all around what she's never going to say
is you know these people in those cities
they voted for this what you voted for
I'm not gonna say that she will say that
about white working-class people in Ohio
though
they don't care about the people
like it wouldn't matter I mean the the
honest truth is
that and this hopefully is not news to
you
but it's a tough truth that if if
everyone in that town died from chemical
poisoning
the the joy behars of the world they
they she wouldn't care if I should
probably be happy about it
like she she sees you
as utter scum
and it's the same thing for the body
Administration they don't care
speaking of the views a little bit of a
less important topic but I wanted to
mention this because this is also making
the rounds yesterday
uh here's the article in New York Post
it says looks like Liam Neeson will not
be returning as a guest on The View the
Irish actor seven years old describes
his appearance on the ABC talk show last
week as embarrassing telling Rolling
Stone the entire segment left him
feeling uncomfortable during his
appearance on the show co-host Joy Behar
couldn't help but air out her longtime
crush on the taken actor in fact the
segment included a montage of clips that
showed Behar making bizarre on-air
comments
um Nissan said I was in the dressing
room drinking a cup of tea turned the TV
up and I thought oh this will be great
we're talking about gun violence in
America I agree that it's an American
problem I go on stage and join the
ladies during the break and I was
congratulating them on this discussion
then our segment starts and it's just
all this BS with joy and Liam Neeson and
having a crush uh and he says I'm
uncomfortable in those situations
and he said it was embarrassing
so that's how I thought I just want to
go back he feels embarrassed by it uh
and uh and here's the we'll play a
little bit of the clip of
these women hitting on Liam Neeson
please welcome Liam Neeson let's talk
about you so much I feel like you've
been
thinking about it
don't blow up my coverage so he wants to
get taken by you
I love it
I got this Valentine from you today
I'm trying to say Liam X and then I and
I was like oh and I find out you gave it
to all of us
she won't believe anything that you say
because it's no secret that Joy thinks
you're oh the hottest and the greatest
ever and
in case
in case there was any doubt we have a
few times she brought you up over the
years I think we have some videos I
would just like to have my ashes
sprinkled over Liam Neeson
there's room in my heart for Steve and
for Liam Neeson let's say
Liam Neeson right now are those
kidnapping movies that he does get me so
aroused I can't I can't even watch this
I can't even sit through this this is
this is like a human rights violation
this is this is I mean
you couldn't even do this with someone
at Guantanamo Bay this is like uh this
is
and Liam Neeson yeah he's a leftist all
that he was complaining about because he
wanted to go talk about gun violence gun
violence is only an American problem
doesn't it right gun violence doesn't
exist did you know that did you know
that there's no gun violence anywhere
else in the world we're the only country
where people get shot uh it only happens
here so he's he's all that but even so
you got to feel some sympathy for the
guy I mean this is like can you imagine
a worse
uh nightmare I mean this is a worst
punishment this is this is worse than
than what happened to Donald dilbeck
last night uh having to sit with the
ladies of the view being sexually
harassed sitting next to Joy Behar being
not only sexually harassed by her in
person but then you have to sit there
and they put the reaction so they've got
the clips of her to make all these
creepy sexual comments about Liam Neeson
and then the reaction of Him Live having
to watch this while sitting next to her
it's just that's not right to do that
someone and this is sexual harassment
right
now I know we said in the opening the
whole uh uh imagine that the situations
were reversed saying it it gets lame
after a while because there are so many
double standards these we spend all day
on the right pointing out double
standards even so uh this is we we
should still note
obviously a double standard like you you
know if if we were to imagine a scenario
where it was a bunch of men on some kind
of talk show and a woman comes on and
it's the same sort of thing uh talking
about uh he uh he wants to be taken by
you and then and then about you playing
a montage of sexual comments made of it
would be everybody involved would be
fired it would be me too everyone's
fired
um and yet
one of the most grotesque women in the
country gets away with it
so
my sympathy does go to Liam Neeson
all right uh also this important report
from a daily wire transgender patients
who undergo hormone therapy have a
significantly increased risk of serious
health problems such as stroke heart
attack and Pulmonary embolism according
to a new study a new study presented at
an American College of Cardiology
conference found that transgender
patients who take cross-sex hormones had
an increased risk of dangerous blood
clots that can create blockages in the
brain heart and lungs uh the study found
the subjects had nearly seven times the
risk of Strokes six times the risk of
the most severe type of heart attack
nearly five times the risk of pulmonary
embolism compared to those with gender
dysphoria who never used hormone therapy
Dr Ibrahim Ahmed said it's all about
risks and benefits starting
transitioning is a big part of a
person's life and helping them feel more
of themselves but hormone replacement
therapy also has a lot of side effects
it's not a risk-free endeavor
who would have thoughts
who would have thought just injecting
hormones into into someone
to bring their perception
bring to try to bring their body into a
line with their perception of themselves
who thought that would have
catastrophic
long-term health effects so everything
we've heard from the media and from the
medical establishment they've been
insisting this for years they've been
telling it to parents and kids and and
patients also who are not uh who are not
kids
they've been saying
it's it's entirely safe it's completely
safe
it's all nonsense
there they are lying
as I've always been saying they they
couldn't even there's no way for them to
know that in the first place
because this is experimental what we're
doing
right now
and it's never been done on this scale
anything close to the scale before in
history
and so the people that were doing it too
now undergoing they're going to go in
the the quote-unquote medical transition
they are the test subjects
so we know to begin with anything they
say about safe it's long-term there's no
way to know that you can't possibly know
that
however we can know again using our
common sense that it's obviously
dangerous to do and there are
consequences anytime you put a a
chemical into somebody's body there are
consequences for it it's never a
consequence so whenever you hear a claim
that's so yeah there's no problem at all
no consequences
that's a huge red flag run the other
direction
because there are always going to be
consequences
okay there are side effects taking
Tylenol there are dangers of taking
Tylenol so and when you're injecting
hormones in yourself of course they're
going to be consequences
obviously it's not a risk-free endeavor
anything close to that
but now since we've been doing this to
people for at a at a Rel at a pretty
large scale for several years now that's
when we're now going to really start to
see so now they have you know they've
got their crop of test subjects and now
we're starting to get the results
and um this is only just the beginning
and it only is going to get worse from
here
all right
one other quick thing before we get to
the comments section
CNET has this report plant-based milk
Alternatives can keep calling themselves
can keep calling themselves milk
according to the U.S Food and Drug
Administration on Wednesday
so plant-based milk is allowed to still
refer to itself as milk says the FDA the
agency commission commissioned and
conducted focus groups and found that
the term milk is strongly rooted in
consumers vocabulary when describing and
talking about plant-based Alternatives
consumers are aware that plant-based
milks are different from dairy milks
research found they also use the
plant-based Alternatives in the same way
people use Dairy milks and cereals
coffee and more although many
plant-based milk alternatives are
labeled with names that bear the term
milk they do not purport to be nor are
they represented as milk oh really
they don't purport to be milk when they
it says milk on the carton if that's not
purporting to be milk
so they're allowed to continue this lie
the FDA no surprise the FDA gets it
wrong again
this is nonsense I'm sorry look you you
trust consumers to know that it's not
actually milk
they don't know that and besides when
did these bureaucrats start trusting
consumers to know things I mean that's
why they have warning labels on
mattresses saying don't use it as a
flotation device right don't don't bring
this to the beach and try to float on in
the Atlantic Ocean that's why they put
they put signs on the highway saying
that the roads are slippery when it's
wet that's why they have uh you know
it's a million examples they have
warning labels on sleeping pills saying
warning may cause drowsiness so they
don't have any uh faith
in the ability of consumers to to know
things and to figure things out and yet
suddenly when it comes to this they're
like yeah people have figured out they
know
since when do you have that sort of
faith in people
and this is the one area where they
actually should have the warning label
warning this coconut milk is not milk
coconuts do not lactate this is a liquid
secretion from a fruit it is not milk
something like that
because that's honest
and it also pays due respect to actual
milk which is something that's important
to me as you know as someone who uh
is is the opposite of lactose intolerant
I don't I don't believe in lactose
intolerance we we are a lactose
welcoming household and yet
they're all these products appropriating
the lactose identity when in fact they
are merely
discharge emitted from fruits and nuts
which is not milk I've already explained
to you many times okay almond milk it's
not milk that is nut discharge that's
what it is you might not like it but
that's what it is and you ought to know
that in order to say it on a card
FDA fumbles the ball yet again big
surprise let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah the control room is complaining
because I called uh almond milk nut
discharge well
this is what this week's been all about
right it's been all about being blunt
and honest and we we've had this
conversation and I believe calling
something I I you know we call a thing
what it is you know that's my it's one
of my most important principles in life
and uh yes and we should apply it we
should especially apply it to the things
that are in our refrigerator you should
know what you're consuming that's all
I'm trying to say uh Patrick says Steve
Harvey has to be one of the goat game
show hosts
um I'm curious how Matt would rank them
it's an interesting question so game
show hosts Alex Trebek obviously is
number one you know I don't think that
that's controversial I'm gonna put Pat
Sajak number two because he's been in
this game for a long time and uh and he
even yeah Alex Trebek's still my number
one Pat Sajak is like is even more
though the prototypical game show host
when you think of a game shows I think
you think of Pat Sajak
um he even has a great game show host
name and then number three I put Bob
Barker
I think he put him in and then maybe
Steve Harvey would be number four and
then uh number five maybe Regis Philbin
so he's in the top five uh not top three
he's not but he's not he's not he's not
goat yet he's not at that status and I
don't think anyone's ever going to be
Alex Trebek
um
magnificent Ginger Snap says one perk of
being a tomboy Sam Britton will never
steal my luggage if my Adidas duffel did
happen to catch his eye his refer
euphoric thrill of stealing it would
fade quickly when he realizes it's full
of Carhartt and flannel
well you know maybe this this is like
the one good argument for gender bending
if you're a woman I guess you make a
good point
because it's for women this is It's the
only Sam Britain deterrent it's the only
way just pack a bunch of men's clothes
it's the only way to guarantee that Sam
Britton won't get you at the baggage
claim so there's an argument for that
um
Jacqueline says Matt maybe you didn't
realize how big is uh getting the
movement that you started Against Child
mutilation but on February 9th
um a member of the Mexican Congress
introduced a bill to make child
mutilation castration a prescription of
hormones to Children illegal in our
country I know this is thanks to you you
started this in Tennessee and now it's
happening in Mexico thanks so much for
everything you do uh well it's it's
thanks to
a movement of which I'm a part but I'm
not certainly far from the only the only
person but I am very happy to see that
yeah we've talked about how it's
spreading across the United States not
just the United States though it's also
it also is a global movement as more and
more country we see this in Europe also
um
more and more countries are beginning to
pull back from a lot of this stuff
took too long never should have happened
to begin with
but at least it's happening now
uh then uh the greatest thing about this
week is that Matt got all the grifters
on YouTube to expose themselves by
attacking him
I've seen a lot of comments like this
and I to be clear
um I that's not what happened because
the people who criticized me are not
grifters
and this has become a point of annoyance
for me is I mean I appreciate that
you're supporting me when you say that
but
uh not everyone's a grifter like a
grifter doesn't mean someone you
disagree with somebody could be wrong
about everything it doesn't make a
grifter uh it's not what grifting is
there there are plenty of grifters out
there especially in the media space
but the people I addressed this week
um
people I was addressing specifically in
you know that that video are not
grifters so Jeremy from the quartering
and Temple and Amala Kenobi Sydney
Watson none of them are grifters in fact
I appreciate all their work uh you
should subscribe to their channels and
you should follow their work as well we
disagreed on this one issue which is
fine
um but they still have lots of valuable
things to contribute and it is it is
possible it's possible to not only
disagree with discreet passionately as I
obviously did without saying oh you know
this person has no Integrity they're
totally worthless
now if I think that about someone if I
think they have no Integrity that
there's we shouldn't listen to anything
they say you know I I'm not going to
hesitate to tell you that there are
people plenty of people who I feel that
way about and I will tell you that's not
the case for these for these people
um what is a what's a grifter a grifter
is someone just to be clear about this
grifter someone who they just know the
word for hypocrite it's someone who who
pretends to believe things they don't
believe and in the media space they're
pretending it because they want to
they're trying to get attention they're
trying to get clicks and they want to
monetize it so they're they're
pretending to be something they aren't
they're pretending to believe things
they don't believe
that's grifting and yes there there's a
lot of it that happens in the media
there's a lot of it that you can find on
social media there's a lot of it among
uh you know self-proclaimed
quote-unquote influencers
but it has nothing to do with
disagreement it also has nothing to do
necessarily with being wrong if you're
wrong if you express a Viewpoint that
happens to be wrong
but you really believe it then that's
not a scam or a con or a grift it's just
you're just wrong
well Jordan Peterson has a new five-part
series out on daily wire plus called
vision and Destiny that is designed to
help you find Clarity and Direction
considering the chaos most of the world
seems to be in with mental health issues
Skyrock especially among teenagers Odair
said couldn't have come at a better time
so here's a clip from vision and Destiny
check it out
there's an infinite number of gender
identities it's like yeah if you want to
play it that way that's true because the
amount of variability in a
five-dimensional space is it's
unbelievably large you could say with no
reason to be contradicted that every
single person on the planet in some
sense has a unique gender identity if
you associate gender with temperament
because every person is unique in their
particular constellation of personality
and so
you if you want to conflate those two
things then you can
um it starts to become very problematic
when you additionally conflate them with
sex it's like well sex and gender and
temperament they're all the same thing
it's like well actually they're not and
the reason they're not is because to say
it again you need a man and a woman to
produce a child
and I'm excited to watch that entire
thing because this is actually this is
if you watch what is a woman of course
we were one of my favorite interviews to
to do is with Jordan Peterson we talk
about this exact issue uh where this
conflation of personality and gender
identity and people is to talk about
gender identity but they're really
trying to describe if they're trying to
describe anything all they're trying to
describe just their personality of
course you don't need the term gender
identity to describe that so we had a
long conversation about that in the film
but you know this is a film so you got
to cut everything down ends up being
just a couple minutes
um so here's an opportunity to hear all
those things fleshed out and uh and it's
definitely worth watching I know I'll be
watching the first two episodes are out
right now and new episodes are coming
online every single week but it's all
exclusive for daily wire Plus members
you can join now dailywire.com subscribe
and watch vision and Destiny now let's
get to our daily cancellation
foreign
cancellation with Senate Bill 1700 which
is currently making its way through the
Arizona legislature this bill is
definitely not what we're canceling
today as it is a good and necessary
piece of legislation the Arizona State
Senate provides this fact sheet about
the proposed law uh reading out says
the bill requires the Arizona Department
of Education to maintain a list of books
that public educational institutions may
not use or make available to students
including books that are lewd or sexual
promote gender fluidity or gender
pronouns or groom children into
normalizing pedophilia grants parents
the right to request removal of school
district or Charter School library or
classroom materials extends public
review periods for Library materials and
District textbooks and removes
exceptions from District curriculum
approval and school library access
requirements so in summary it takes
overtly sexual books out of the schools
pornographic books out of the schools
and gives parents a say in the material
that their own children are exposed to
this is of course basic common sense and
the only problem
with the law is that it's not a law
already that's the only issue like this
should already be the law
as we've seen there's nothing more
likely to stir up controversy and
outrage than basic Common Sense which is
why this bill in Arizona uh just like
similar bills in Florida and other
places have been met with
Furious protests from from the left at a
hearing this week a teacher named Alicia
messing stood up and made her own case
against the bill she apparently believes
that it is crucially important for
elementary school students to read books
about you know masturbation and gender
fluidity and although she can't explain
why it's so important she can explain
why we should all listen to her opinion
whether her opinion makes sense or not
and the reason is that she has a
master's degree listen
I have a master's degree because when I
got certified I was told I had to have a
master's degree to be an Arizona
certified teacher
we all have advanced degrees what do the
parents have are we vetting the
backgrounds of our parents are we
allowing the parents to choose the
curriculum and the books that our
children are going to read I think that
it's a mistake I'm just speaking from
the heart
the one line that I love is we must
remember that the purpose of public
education is not to teach only what
parents want their children to be taught
it is to teach them what Society needs
them to be taught
you know this meme is overused and
cliched at this point obviously but
listening to that it's the one time when
I'm tempted to respond ma'am this is a
Wendy's mainly because I'm sure this
woman even presents her academic
credentials went in line at the drive
through you know like yeah hi I have a
master's degree also I'd like a number
three meal and a chocolate frosty sorry
man we're out of frosties what did did
you hear me I have a master's degree I
have a master's degree you would dare to
withhold a frosty from a woman with an
advanced degree you scoundrel
but you can't blame Alicia I suppose her
master's degree is utterly useless it's
not good for anything so she'll try to
use it as a trump card in arguments
because she has to get something out of
this piece of paper that she bankrupted
herself to purchase now I say the
master's degree is useless because it is
in the vast majority of cases master's
degrees are nothing but money making
scams for the University system and this
has become so clear that even
left-leaning sites like slate for
example are publishing articles
declaring as they did last year that
master's degrees are one of the biggest
scams in higher education CBS News
finally clued into this issue in May of
this past year publishing a report with
this headline quote many graduate
programs are scams according to higher
education policy analysts the report
begins some 3 million Americans will
enroll in enroll in graduate programs
this year only to work towards degrees
that often aren't worth the time or
money according to an education policy
analyst many undergraduate
undergraduates earn their bachelor's
degree and go straight to graduate
school in hopes of gaining a new degree
or skills that will make them more
attractive to prospective employers well
they're already off on the wrong foot if
they're trying to find skills you know
you don't you don't that's
um gaining skills is the one thing
that you don't do in quote unquote
higher education it's one of the big
problems with it is that you're spending
a lot of time in early adulthood not
learning skills
quote the reason people go makes sense
they go to get a job and make more money
said James Murphy Senior policy analyst
and advocacy group education reform now
the recent research shows that 40 of
Master's programs in the US have no
positive return
if you're taking the cost of attending
and the time spent not working what you
get out of the Master's Degree doesn't
even pay for itself or if you told CBS
News
of course
you should note higher education itself
is usually also a scam master's degrees
aren't even close to worth the
investment in a large number of cases
but that is increasingly becoming true
of all college degrees including
undergraduate degrees
the scam simply becomes more obvious and
more financially costly As you move up
the educational ladder that's why half
of all student debt is now held by
people with graduate degrees and these
are mostly people who you know they want
to stay in college they want to stay in
the college system because they don't
know what else to do and uh they're
afraid to actually start living their
adult lives and and you know getting
people they actually have to learn
skills they don't want to do that so
they just stay in the system
or they do it because they've been
convinced that it's a it's a smart
strategy to spend the first decade of
adulthood stacking degrees even if you
don't know what you're going to do with
them or because as was the case with
Alicia she says the teacher in the clip
they have to get a master's degree in
order to get into the their chosen line
of work
now this third case where they get it
because they have to it doesn't make it
less of a scam but in fact more of a
scam like so many other professions hers
comes with an entirely arbitrary barrier
to entry it requires her to sink herself
even further into debt to obtain what
amounts to nothing more than extremely
expensive calling card
you know signaling that she's a she's a
member of the club
that's why I wouldn't make fun of her
for getting the degree if it's what she
needed to do in order to get the job she
wanted
but the problem is that she's now
pretending that this symbolically
significant token has actual
significance
she says that parents aren't qualified
to determine which books are appropriate
for their own children because the
parents don't have the magical piece of
paper that she has that's not how it
works Alicia if the parents don't have a
master's degree it only means that they
weren't suckered or coerced the way that
you were
that doesn't make them less qualified if
anything it makes them more qualified
after all you don't need a degree to
determine what is appropriate for
children all you need is common sense
and powers of discernment
and we must immediately suspect that
people who blew their money on a useless
Advanced degree are probably lacking in
both of those things
that again this is not really a question
of qualification
it is a question of the proper ordering
of things
it's a question of who's the primary
Earthly authority over a child the
parent or the government who's the
primary caregiver
who has the parental rights does my
child belong to me or the state
is my child my child or is he the
state's child the state's property
and I'm just there as backup
these are the fundamental questions at
play here and these questions have
nothing to do with academic credentials
and the answer right down the line is
the parent
the reason that we give primary
authority to the parent
is not just because it's the parents
right though it is
but also because that's what's best for
the child and you notice how she says at
the end that um
that we shouldn't consider what the
parent wants the child to be taught but
rather what what Society needs the child
to be taught
but when she says Society she means of
course the institutions that run Society
and those institutions will decide what
they need the child to be taught based
on what sort of person they need the
child to become
in the case of the institutions in
charge of our society today they quote
unquote need our children to be morally
and intellectually vacuous vassals of
the state
with no firm sense of self no
understanding of their own identity
who could be easily placated and
manipulated
those are the sorts of people they need
and so they want them to be educated in
a way that will produce those results
but here's an alternative idea
what should we teach the child
well
maybe we should teach the child what the
child needs to know
okay it's not what Society needs the
child to know it's what the child needs
to know maybe you should take the
child's needs into account first and
foremost
rather than teaching based on the needs
of society I.E the institutions perhaps
we should be teaching based on the needs
of the actual child the student
and the fact that this option wasn't
even mentioned by the teacher that she
hadn't so much as considered this
tells you all you need to know
and as far as what kids need to know
well we certainly know that they don't
need to know about gender ideology and
gender fluidity and whatever else this
teacher wants to shove into their minds
they don't need to be exposed to that in
fact they need to not be exposed to it
and that is ultimately why this teacher
and her master's degree are today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block if you're
not a member yet become a member and use
code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]